前回の5球で100匹ドッキリわー
ちょっと二行でしたねあ俺のせいじゃないですよ
音はいいかというリアクションにパターンに分かれると思うよけあって叫ぶ人ともう
びっくりしすけで黙っちゃタイプ
台座たのが待ってくださっ開いたため黙って堕胎
黙っちゃうタイプなんでああいう結果になっちゃったと思うんですけど今回は
確実にひとめますんですよね今回はこちらのえっ
ショックギャグペンっていうのを買ってきましたはい
こういう感じです
えっとにドンキで買ったかな松江だけ全流が流れますこの
確か嫉妬してるとねええええ
楽しみだなよくテレビで見てわかるんですよの質って行ったら
パチってない奴それです
すごいシンプルなドッグ位なんですけどやっぱドッキリバッター始めとしてはシンプル
なドッキリをしっかりコーヒ決めていく
そういうところのやっぱりこのドッキリます体の3つが始まってると思うんだよ
今回も広範囲後輩にね今でも連作るんですけど
後半にバッチリ決めてやろうかです
そしてこんななんか
当たってシンプルですねえっ
バーチっていうのかな
主としてみますね離婚はタバコ f 5位
俺が嫌だわフェア世界てきた
いっぱい投げますてみましょう強い酸っぱくてもでもしなきゃいけないんだろ
ああ
あんたかっ
怖いの一平者1回だけでパ
アジアはないとダメなんだよ
えぇでもで散ってしたみたいな
でペッグだーっっ
あっはぁ
って本当に
フィラーっっ
今これが号ないのだと思ってんしょん
ドイツ語の勉強してて
ちょっと俺がノートにドイツ語書いてみてよって今米を渡して家たち
てされます
すざそれくると思うんで
一匹ですこう twitter の
好きなん
おっ局在待つと開けろ
dare ん
ん
ねええええ
打つべき予想
のび太がああ
5いつあるん
このやるようなんん
うーんまだいい八女市はなんで学んだというかううう入ったビッグでした
ビックリしたと言ってなかったけどそんな酒がやったよ
ドイツ語書いて
非常にさてとってあげるただメインまずん
てかー
スプーンっ今日は俺の下ボケの雅紀があために来てるんだよ
ドイツ語回答ございますまたねあさなちゃんならいいんだけど
ale
me
ん
ええええっ
ale
なりますよちょっと待ってよいいこというかもっ
まあねションって何が違う母なんやなぁ
ちょっと待って俺がどうか戦目かと思っていますよ
ああ
ちょっと待ってくれよまじかー
おっ
true
dea
ずっとも言えない感じになりましたねー
今やっぱりドッキリの修行が足りないのかなそうだね
まだまだだね場数を踏まないと貧しいけれど持ったよ
nerd 依存と全然ダメじゃんもういうというわけで満席でした
じゃ俺えっ